I hate this and I'm sorry and did I did
I say that I hate this because I hate
this you don't need to apologize for
making a huge sacrifice to save your
friends this is why people love moral
philosophy professors how about this
every time you see me get a stomachache
imagine I'm thinking of you so all the
time exactly
sorry to interrupt I wanted to give both
of you something before we do this think
of it as a going-away present
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't normally cry at movies that was
pretty good my girl was hot
my guy was - I'm gonna miss you so much
Eleanor except you won't that's what's
so scary about this whole thing I'm
gonna miss you you're just gonna think
I'm some sexy godlike figure who you
want to hump immediately after meeting
her you know you're deflecting by making
jokes about haha it's not a joke I'm a
legit but I believe in you I'm not even
scared to get rebooted because I know
that you'll be here taking care of me I
wish we had more time together the whole
time means nothing
Jeremy bear me baby we'll just get
through this and then you and I can
chill out and the dot of the eye forever
right we'll be okay we found each other
before hundreds of times we can do it
again
by cheating
you